darkest dungeon is a game about managing
the many stresses of being an adventurer
for hire
fighting undead skeletons investigating
old torture devices and exploring
abandoned crypts is really quite hellish
work and it leaves its mark on the human
psyche this is represented in the game
by a stress meter which is the white bar
below the little red health bar
underneath each character since darkest
dungeon is a turn-based strategy game
you can see our party of the Highwaymen
crusader plague doctor and Vestal is
taking turns unleashing their various
abilities on some pesky skeletons which
abilities they can use isn't determined
by some sort of mana pool or magic
points or anything like that instead
it's all about positioning where each
character is on the lineup is very
important as it determines which
abilities they can use and who they can
attack as you can see here these
skeleton with the shield is a heavy
hitter but can only reach either our
highwaymen or our crusader as those two
are in the front two spots meanwhile our
Vestal and plague doctor are safer in
the back where they can heal and toss
out poisonous grenades respectively now
not all attacks in darkest dungeon deal
physical damage some deal stress damage
instead if a party member gets too
stressed they will either steal their
resolve and keep on fighting or they'll
snap and start panicking a panicked
party member may hide in the back or
push their way to the front and a
murderous frenzy they may attack friends
or take no action at all in short you
have to tend to the minds of your troops
and not just their bodies one way you
can do that is by camping when you camp
in darkest dungeon each character has
camping specific abilities they can use
to help bolster the spirits of either
themselves or the party you can feast on
delicious rations to reduce stress or as
you can see here the vessel is going to
use her prey ability to heal our party's
wounds and reduce their stress after
playing through the demo for darkest
dungeon I found the game to be
reminiscent of XCOM in a lot of ways
both are highly strategic games with an
emphasis on positioning and squad based
tactics and when things start to go bad
they can very very quickly spiral out of
control darkest dungeon is tough but if
you're smart and key
cool head it's not hopeless the
developers hope to have an early access
version of the game out sometime later
this year thanks for watching and I'll
see you all next time